your doctor may recommend testosterone
replacement therapy if the level of
testosterone in your bloodstream is
significantly lower than normal
testosterone is a male hormone also
called an androgen which is produced in
your testicles testosterone promotes the
development of male sexual
characteristics and supports masculine
functions such as sperm production and
sexual desire this hormone is also
essential for maintaining bone density
red blood cell level muscle mass and a
sense of well-being
low levels of testosterone in your blood
may result in a condition called
androgen deficiency or hypogonadism
which may include increased body fat
reduced muscle size and swollen breasts
if your testosterone level is low you
may experience reduced sex drive
erectile dysfunction and low sperm count
leading to infertility a deficiency in
testosterone affects all parts of your
body and may also cause loss of body
hair increased body fat decreased muscle
mass diminished bone density which can
lead to osteoporosis mild anemia swollen
or tender breasts hot flashes decreased
energy and depression
testosterone replacement therapy is the
administration of manmade testosterone
to raise the level of this hormone in
your blood back to normal and to relieve
your symptoms you can take testosterone
therapy via an injection patch gel or
tablet if you have injections you will
receive one every two to three weeks
the testosterone will be delivered into
the muscle of your buttocks if you use a
testosterone skin patch you will place a
patch on your arm back abdomen or upper
buttocks you will change the patch daily
if you use testosterone gel you will
apply it daily to the skin on your
shoulder upper arm or abdomen if you use
buccal tablets you will place one tablet
on your gum line twice a day